[Music]
foreign
you're never too old to learn anything
new whether it's an art a new language a
new sport or learning new skills to
advance your career hi I'm Phillip I'm
61 years old and last year I upskill was
simply learn this postgraduate program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the I.T sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course funny
story I want to share with you
I started off that's fine to be a DJ
where I became interested in electronic
stereo systems and how they connected
and how they operate and what made them
function and four years ago I began a
journey to understand and learn more
about the cloud on the way I developed a
natural understanding for the security
needs and began to focus my studies to
understand more about the cyber security
aspect of the cloud landscape
I worked with many companies before the
security analyst and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at Prince George in
college and been in many different
learning and training experiences but
the experience as a student is simply
learning something I will always cherish
of course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors because I
believe in living a fulfilling life at
61. I am still trained students in
martial arts I've been practicing
martial arts for the past 40 years and
my efforts were acknowledged by the
Eastern United States International
Martial Arts Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication Services martial arts I've
been many things in my life
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first